so i i think the most important thing
that we have to look i think the most
important thing that was how
how we move forward as a sport how we
move forward as a society as well i
think this is deeper than just cricket i
think what we need to do
is
is address what's what's happened um and
find ways of educating more find ways of
moving forward
um and and really looking at um
you know areas in which we as a
as a sport and beyond that as well um
can can really look to to better that
you know but better society and better
the game
okay let's go to laura then bbc please
hi joe
i just wondered if this whole scandal in
golf in yorkshire has affected your
pride as a yorkshire player and perhaps
made you consider your future there
um
that is obviously deep deeply hurtful
it's happened at a club that i'm so you
know i'm
i'm so close to and it means so much for
me to to to go and play for yorkshire um
in terms of my position
if you're not at the club how can you
make any change how can you help move
things forward
and and as i said i look look forward to
speaking to to lord patel at some point
in the future about how i can i can help
move things forward but
um
you know that's that's my position on
things and um you know we'll see how
that happens in in the future
okay let's move to tom parmesan please
at sky news
hello joe um
you've been at this club since 2007. can
you
say here today that you've never
heard or experienced or been aware of
any of the racism that other colleagues
have talked about
not from my not that i can recall no no
i can't
but the thing is what i will say is it's
clear that there's the things have
happened at the club and
um we have to make sure that we you know
we eradicate it and you know we look to
find ways of making sure that this never
happens again in sport and and as i said
earlier beyond that as well within
society
okay let's go to steve scott at itv news
um
hello joe i just wondered whether you
had spoken to
azeem rafiq at all ever since um
he first
spoke about the experiences he had for
yorkshire
steve can i just say that we're not
going to be able to talk about
individuals i said that from the outset
so we're gonna have to move on but happy
to take any general questions
okay um so in that case um
so just to elaborate
the picture of yorkshire county career
club at the moment embroiled in this um
racism scandal it's not a culture that
you recognize
over your time there
no i can only speak from my own personal
experiences um
but
like i said the thing that's really
disappointing is that this has happened
and that we have to find a way to move
forward we have to look at finding a way
to to educate as much as we can and make
sure that you know that these are hard
learnings that we can
um you know eradicate from from the
sport and make sure that you know
moving forward as a county we um we
really can
make a difference in this area um
i mentioned it in my in my statement you
look at the work that the current
england teams have been doing over the
last few years it's something that we ki
we care deeply about
we're passionate about and we really
want to make um make a difference in and
i think now that's
this shouldn't just apply to yorkshire
they should apply
across across the game they should
um you know every every county should be
looking at making find ways to
um to eradicate racism from from the
sport and
um i think it's really important that we
you know we look to do that
okay we'll take two more
before moving on we're going to go to
rory dollard and then martin ziegler to
finish go ahead rory
thanks thanks joe
um yeah yesterday you know the matter as
you know has reached the houses of
parliament um and yesterday the culture
minister said that anyone found guilty
of racism
a slap on the wrists is not enough and
and suggested that they should basically
be
removed from the game or or not be
picked anymore for their representative
teams
do you
do you share that
resolve that anyone found guilty should
be
pushed out or do you think there's room
for rehabilitation and education
how do you say so sit on that one
i think i think it's very good question
i think that from my point of view
um you know we all make mistakes and you
know there's
racism is is something that we
completely have to eradicate that
and
um
but i do think people deserve a second
chance and if they're willing to show um
you know to to accept
that they've made a mistake and they
want to make change and they want to
move forward and i think that's really
important as well um
you know we're all human beings um and
i think it's that's you know something
that we
um we have to remember within this that
um
of course
people have been
deeply hurt throughout this whole whole
thing and uh but ultimately we've got to
find a way to move forward
and the last question on this particular
topic martin ziegler then we'll move
back to james cole to talk about uh
ash's preparation thank you go ahead
martin
are you there martin can't hear you
not sure if you're on mute yeah you're
on mute at the moment there we go you
can hear me now sorry yeah come here
joe with the benefit of hindsight and
looking retrospectively do you feel that
you you didn't after yourself to sort of
keep an eye on what was happening at
yorkshire and
looking out for people who might be
having troubles around it
around in this particular
um all these incidents which we've heard
about
i mean did things really just go
completely over your head
like i said i've spent a long time
reflecting on um
you know what
you know what's happened
um
i think more than anything
i think more than anything it's really
important that
um
we recognize what has happened we make
sure that
moving forward we we never see this
happen again
and whether it's at yorkshire whether
it's in club cricket um whether it's in
you know
out in the street or whatever
we've got to find a way of
of you know confronting this and
stopping it and making sure that
absolutely we are um
getting getting rid of racism from
society